German car makers have come to the
International Motor Show in Frankfurt
with concepts for electric drive and
autonomous driving and they're taking
the offensive but there's also plenty of
time and space devoted to the familiar
makes and models Porsche has unveiled
the 911 gt3 Touring package a special
version of one of the world's most
famous sports cars Porsches Oliver Bluma
describes it as a special model based on
one from 1973 Porsche asked its
customers what they wanted to see and
this was it
the gt3 Touring comes only with a
six-speed stick shift but its 368
kilowatts slam it from 0 to 100 km/h in
just 3.9 seconds another classic and new
close is the Ford Mustang here debuting
its newly designed front and the Ford
Fiesta is demonstrating its diversity
with new variants
what does curette knows that anyone who
follows developments in the automotive
industry will be familiar with concepts
beyond the cars themselves such as
individual mobility solutions for today
tomorrow and the day after important
links in the chain are the suppliers
they've been concentrating on enhancing
safety and comfort while cutting back on
emissions among shufflers priorities our
top performance high voltage hybrid
modules and electric axles for battery
powered vehicles without internal
combustion engines ZF is presenting its
innovative ideas and solutions under the
slogan see think act ZF Stefan summer
envisions accident and emissions free
driving in the long term so they're
refining their technology in the field
of sensors artificial intelligence and
mechanics the drive concepts aren't the
only aspects undergoing fundamental
changes the interiors of the future will
also be radically different 80 and
developed seat and space concepts ad ins
Antonius mass wolf believes the car will
eventually be a third living space and
these spaces will increasingly merge to
form an office or a living room on
wheels the cars functionality itself
will evolve
howdy provides an example of how the
components might go together
the Elena Nikon concept vehicles are all
electric and self-driving as well Odie's
Rupert's tedlar describes the Elaine as
the embodiment of their vision of
autonomous driving with level 4 the
driver sits in the driver's seat as
usual impresses the artificial
intelligence button to switch over to
autonomous driving the second concept
vehicle the icon takes it one step
further for level five of autonomous
driving the designers have removed a few
old standards
the Audi's mark Vista points out that
level five dispenses with a steering
wheel and has an all-new layout the
seats in front are first class and their
space in the rear lounge for two more
pass
Ginger's another thing that takes me
fishing as montes explains this
technology isn't ready for volume
production yet so the newest generation
of the classic London taxi still
requires human drivers anyway autonomous
systems don't help lift the baggage dear
consignment [ __ ] and done off with
the younger package this London taxi is
powered by a 110 kilowatt electric motor
made by Siemens Volkswagen promise to
push development of electric drive and
an initial result appearing at the Motor
Show is the roadmap II the ID KRAS
concept is the third of five
all-electric models
Volkswagen plans to roll out starting in
2020 even so VW CEO Matthias Mueller
doesn't see a complete extinction of the
internal combustion engine coming
anytime soon
he intends to keep on developing
internal combustion engine technology as
a bridge to electric that's necessary to
achieve our country's ambitious co2
reduction goals until immobility is
well-established
and considering that car buying
decisions are generally driven by
emotion there's the compact SUV T Rock
which is joined by the new Polo GTI
Daimler would seem to be afflicted with
a split personality as well Smart has
announced that the transition to
electric Drive will be complete by 2020
in both Europe and America now smarts
going a step further with the EQ for two
concept the first robot taxi able to
communicate with its surroundings
without a steering wheel this concept
could revolutionize urban mobility a
[Music]
major crowd-pleaser is the AMG concept 1
the beating heart of this hybrid hyper
car is the drivetrain from their 2015
formula 1 racer the 735 kilowatt system
performance carries this car from zero
to 200 km/h in under six seconds even at
3 million euros apiece
all 275 units have already been sold
hyundai also seems to focus more on fun
than sustainability the i30 n has a
sporting exterior with red accents and
spoilers in front and back inside the
driving mode switch can now be found on
the steering wheel
SCOTUS karak is another part of its SUV
model offensive the leaner dimensions
make the Kodiaks little brother a bit
easier to handle and a more suitable SUV
for urban mobility it will be hitting
showrooms in November
yet another compact crossover for city
driving is sayit's aronia among its
unique selling points are the many ways
to customize it and it's cutting edge
safety and connectivity technology Opel
is taking its family of SUVs up range
with the Grande land ex joining the
mocha and Crossland as the third member
of the ex family this is opals first
plug-in hybrid
[Music]
Toyota has plans to offer two hybrid
drives with different orientations for
its models one has ecology in mind while
the other emphasizes power and dynamics
an example of this new strategy is the
CHR high power concept
the luxury hybrid limousine LS 500 HP
Lexus is a real eye-catcher its system
performance of 264 kilowatts is due to
hit showroom floors at the end of this
year the mine mattis's found that here
at Frankfurt opinions are still divided
on the optimum type of drive for cars
some appear to long for the days before
pollution badges and air quality alerts
others would rather see road
transportation go all-electric today
than tomorrow but it's wishful thinking
don't want to turn the clock back or
forward the transition takes time and
history has shown that the internal
combustion engine has lots of
development potential it can be made a
lot cleaner amatis expects some
innovations there in the future before
we're ready for cars to go autonomous
and all-electric body autos Elbe drying
electric farm